die gängige technik der datenspeicherung
ist alles andere als effektiv und
geständig und deswegen so den
forschungsteams weltweit nach
alternativen speicher methoden fachleute
der university parat haben sich jetzt
die natur zum vorbild genommen und eine
methode entwickelt mit der bestimmte
biomoleküle quasi in bits und bytes
umgewandelt werden können ein teelöffel
angehäuft mit solchen krediten könnte
tatsächlich den inhalt ganzer
bibliotheken enthalten klicks und
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
die natur nutzt schon seit jahrmillionen
biomoleküle um große mengen an
informationen zu speichern und
weiterzugeben
das ist nicht nur besonders effektiv
sondern auch von großer beständigkeit
ganz anders als unsere speicher methoden
denken wir mal an die wirklich begrenzte
lebensdauer von herkömmlichen
speichermedien wie festplatten oder dvds
das digitale vergessen wird außerdem
durch die ständige weiterentwicklung von
hard und software begünstigt denn so
werden ältere dateiformate und
datenträger unlesbar forschungsteams
weltweit sind schon seit längerer zeit
daran die technik der natur in sachen
datenspeicherung nach zu haben und auch
für das wissen der menschheit nutzbar zu
machen 2017 hatten fachleute aus new
york eine methode vorgestellt mit der
digitale information in der dna
gespeichert werden können erforscht
wurde bislang außerdem wie ein digitales
bild in einer lebenden bakterien
gespeichert werden kann über beides
hatten wir jemand kriegst du mir
berichtet eine neue ziemlich
ausgetüftelte methode kommt jetzt von
einem forschungsteam der harvard
university die fachleute nutzen quasi
kleine peptid verbindungen als bits und
bytes peptide sind zum beispiel relativ
komplexe moleküle die in unserem körper
bestimmte aufgaben über die dazu
schreibt das team in seiner studie
diese strategie des schreibens und leser
es erlaubt es mit nur einer kleinen
anzahl von molekülen viele formen der
information zu kodieren so weiß bereits
im ersten test gelungen einen
japanischen holzschnitt zu kodieren
genauso wie einen bekannten vortrag des
physikers richard feynman zur
nanotechnologie
dieser neue ansatz nutzt das
unterschiedliche molekulargewicht
kleinster petit verbindung um die
informationen in diesen olivo peptiden
zu probieren ist lediglich ihre
anwesenheit in der mischung entscheidend
anders übrigens als bei dna codes die
eigens produziert werden müssen
bei den uni copeptin steht ihre an-
beziehungsweise abwesenheit jemals für
eine 1 oder 1 0
laut dem harvard forschungsteam werden
so maximal acht olivo peptide gebraucht
um ein byte an informationen zu
speichern
dazu heißt es in der studie wir
komplettieren diesen wien er brot in
einen molekularen code in dem wir jedem
der acht tritt sony copeptin zuordnen
ein molekül chip der beispielsweise den
buchstaben k speichert weiß genau vier
spezifische moleküle auf vier weitere
oli gruppe dagegen fehlen die abläufe im
chip lautet 0 1 0 0 1 0 1 1 was den
buchstaben a entsprechen diese codes
werden in dem molekül chips mit hilfe
der so genannten liquid händlers
gespeichert dabei handelt es sich um
gängige computergesteuerte laborgeräte
die masse der moleküle kann durch die
analyse mit einem massenspektrometer
bestimmt werden und das wiederum lässt
dann auf den geschriebenen lego
petticoat schließen also ganz simpel
jedes peptid hat ein ganz bestimmtes
gewicht und je nachdem welche oligopole
in dem acht mit strang enthalten sind
weist dieser stand ein ganz bestimmtes
gewicht aus auf dem man genau auf den
code zum beispiel das gras fließen kann
laut der studie erlaubt dies dass die
informationen mit 99,9 prozent
wiederherstellungs präzision geschrieben
gespeichert und gelesen wird
20 bits pro sekunde beträgt die
lesegeschwindigkeit derzeit was jetzt
unglaublich lachen ist im vergleich vom
heutigen speichern sd karten können das
mit bis zu 300.000 mal schnellere
geschwindigkeit aber die
schreibgeschwindigkeit soll noch
deutlich erhöht werden die ganze methode
hat laut der fachleute enorme vorteile
denn die oligopol sie sind nicht nur
sehr robust sondern auch extrem haltbar
auch bei extremer trockenheit hohen
temperaturen und in umgebung ohne
sauerstoff und ohne licht und das bei
hunderten bis tausenden jahren in
zukunft könnte dies laut des
forschungsteams nicht nur mit oli
copeptin funktionieren sondern auch mit
anderen molekülen die eine definierte
masse besitzen so könnten also auch
fettsäuren oder aromatische
kohlenwasserstoffe dafür genutzt werden
daten zu speichern
doch auch die datendichte der molekül
speicherchips soll zukünftig verbessert
werden derzeit besitzen die aktuell
genutzten labor chips 384 mikroben die
entscheidend für die anzahl und größe
der datendichte sind ein möglicher
lösungsansatz wäre es einen
modifizierten tintenstrahldrucker zu
nutzen der einzelnen tropfen als
speicher bord erzeugt und so eine
deutlich höhere datendichte möglich wird
dazu der beteiligte forscher brian
pattie theoretisch könnten damit eines
tages die gesamte öffentliche bibliothek
von new york in einem teelöffel
gespeichert werden wenn das realität
wird berichten wir natürlich hier
darüber und wenn er das nicht verpassen
wollen dann klickt hier drauf denn nur
oft telegram könnt ihr klicks und
nämlich so abonnieren dass er garantiert
kein video verpasst und dort bekommt er
die videos nicht nur früher sondern es
gibt diskussionsgruppen ihr könnt safe
themen vorschläge machen und über allem
bin ich dabei zudem gehört es nicht zur
facebook-daten grad
wir sehen uns also hoffentlich
aufstellung bis dann bleibt dran